I like English maths and lunch I like
the times you but when we do maths
science
especially lunch
every morning ask children about the
best part of school and many will stay
lunch time in one of London's most
deprived boroughs the school meal is
often the most important of the day
we don't get hurting bellies and there's
enough energy
for for learning I like lunch because I
like to get a hot meal on the table I
like to eat and also so that I don't
complain I have a I have a tummy
I have a stomachache
fresh fruit and vegetables quality
ingredients and locally sourced products
could now disappear from School menus
unraveling Decades of progress
if the the impact then rolls itself and
Cascades and eventually gets to that
kitchen and we then start churning out
fast food low quality meals that are not
healthy for the children it then creates
the whole issue around the Obesity
challenge that we're trying to tackle
the challenge of unhealthy meals in
unhealthy habits that then lead to later
on in life
foreign
Caterers say the rising cost of food
will force them to abandon National
guidance on healthy and nutritious
School meals
we currently cook from scratch
everything in our small meals but again
we might be having to consider using
some processed food some sauce mixes and
the like moving forward
says nearly 2 million children have
access to free School meals and that the
Chancellor's New Growth plan will raise
living standards for everyone
it told Sky News we are also supporting
schools with 53.8 billion pounds in core
funding this year and a 4 billion pound
increase in overall funding from 2021 to
2022.
I'd love to send them an impact lunches
every day but we just can't afford to
and the whole point of School meals is
that children who come from low-income
backgrounds have access to good you know
good quality food that they may not be
getting at home
at this school there's a new menu coming
after the half term holidays it is they
say a step backwards sadio Chaudhary Sky
News in newham in London